Speaker 1: Let's go to Soria from New Jersey. I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly. Is it Soria?
Speaker 2: That's pronounced right. I just have a
question regarding. Okay. So I'm I'm currently in
my third week of college, a freshman in college.
So I wanted to ask something about college in
general. Like, what do you think is like the
impact or what are your thoughts on the impact
of like college students in an election?
Because I've seen a lot of things around,
but I'm just wondering your specific thoughts.
Speaker 1: Well, I think the impact is much
smaller than it could be because many college
students don't vote. You know, I think that
it's a group that every election there's
these talking points that are repeated.
If the youngest voters really turn out this
time, it could be an incredible blowout for
the left and then like they never do. So I think
that college age voters have the potential to be
the decision makers in these elections if they
actually turned out. But sadly, they have very
low voter turnout, which is disappointing to me.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So why do you think that's the
case, though? Why do you think college voters
are such a turn out in such low numbers?
Speaker 1: I mean, I think that there's
a couple different things going on.
For some people that age, they've only just become
eligible to vote. So when things become habits,
we tend to just do them more. It's it hasn't
been a habit for a 19 year old to vote. So. So
they're not yet in that habit. And so they may
not do it. Number two, I think there's a lot of
disaffected people that age who don't necessarily
feel as though voting is going to have an impact
or the impact that they want on the world around
them. That's number two. And then number three,
people that age also have a lot of things going
on. And so in kind of a logistical sense, maybe it
seems like more of an inconvenience to go and go
and vote. I think it's a lot of different things.
Speaker 2: That makes sense. Thank you.
Speaker 1: You're going to vote. All right.
Speaker 2: Yeah, of.
Speaker 1: Course. Good, good, good. All right,
good. Well, good luck at college.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good. There is Suria
from New Jersey with a beautiful question.